RETO MEIER: HI.
I'm Reto Meier, Google
Developer Advocate.
Today, I learned how to get
one terabyte of data processed
with Google BigQuery
each month at no cost,
without entering a credit card.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: If you're excited
to explore the BigQuery
public datasets like
these, but you're not
excited about paying for
it, there's great news.
BigQuery lets you process a
terabyte of data every month
at no cost.
Getting started
is quick and easy,
and you don't even need to
enter your credit card details.
We'll get started by navigating
the dock to the BigQuery web
UI.
Or you can go directly to
BigQuery.cloud.google.com.
At this point, you'll need to
sign in using a Google account.
Once you're signed in,
continue to BigQuery.
We'll start by
creating a new project.
If it's our first
one, that means
first reading and accepting the
terms of service for the Google
Cloud Platform.
Eventually, we'll want to take
advantage of the free trial.
But let's dismiss it for
now, and create our project.
You can share data and queries
from BigQuery, so make sure
you give your
project a good name.
Once the project's ready, we'll
get a notification, click that,
and it'll be selected
as our active project.
We're now done, and we
can start running queries.
I'm also going to enable
the BigQuery API here,
so that I can run
programmatic queries later.
Before I run some queries,
let's take a quick peek
at our billing tab.
As you can see, this
is a new project,
so there's no billing
instrument associated with it.
Now, when we head back
to the BigQuery web UI,
we get the BigQuery web UI.
Let's start by querying
the USA names database,
to make sure we can use
that free quota to query
the public datasets.
We query charges
for queries using
one metric, the number
of bytes processed,
rounded to the nearest meg,
with a 10 meg minimum per table,
referenced and data processed.
If you open the
query validator, you
can see the number of bytes that
will be processed by running
the query you have entered.
This is calculated as
the total data processed
for the columns you select, even
if you set an explicit limit.
So it's much more
important to reduce
the number of columns you
process than the number of rows
you return.
When the query returns, the
number of bytes processed
is displayed here,
and your query log
shows the exact number
of billable bytes.
Note that you can preview the
full results of every table
using the Preview
button, so you really
need to select Star on a table.
When you're comfortable
with using BigQuery,
we can add a billing account.
You still get a free
terabyte each month,
but you also get to
upload your own data.
In addition to queries
beyond the first terabyte,
BigQuery also charges you to
store data and stream inserts.
But loading data, or
copying, exporting,
or performing metadata
operations like list, update,
and delete aren't charged.
If you're new to
Google Cloud platform,
you can take advantage
of the free trial.
It will let you continue
experimenting with BigQuery,
still at no cost.
Pricing page, here, has
details on exactly how BigQuery
calculates the
cost of each query,
based on the types of
data in each column.
Here, I've switched to an
account with billing enabled.
So, I can create a new data set,
and query some of my own data.
Here, I'm using data kept
externally on Google Drive,
rather than storing
it within BigQuery.
When you need more than
a terabyte in a month,
you're charged at a rate
of $5.00 per terabyte.
You only pay what
you use, though,
and it's rounded to
the nearest megabyte.
So that works out to
about half a cent per gig.
And note that you can
set cost controls,
so that once your credit
card has been added,
you don't have any
unfortunate surprises.
Tune in each week to learn
more BigQuery tips and tricks.
For now, use your
terabyte of processing
to analyze your own data,
or use our public data
sets to understand the world
and create cool visualizations.
Don't forget to
share them with us,
using the
#todayIlearnedwithBigQuery
hashtag.
And of course,
subscribe to our channel
and follow our blog to learn
something new with BigQuery.